[Music]
hey what's up guys it's marquez from the
mkbhd channel back with another tour of
videos another video in the tour of
series so if you like the idea of this
series give this video a thumbs up and
uh if you have any more suggestions for
things you want to see a tour of like
you know a tour of i don't know my
computer or my desk you know things like
that i'm trying to get a tally of what
people want to see a tour of uh so go
ahead and leave a comment down there if
you have a suggestion but today we're
giving a tour of my phone which as you
can see here is the samsung galaxy nexus
i'm using the stock launch uh or the
stock lock screen as you can see because
i like the functionality where you can
swipe up to text someone back when they
call
anyway if you don't have an android
phone this might be a little bit weird
to you but um this is definitely uh
something i i've got the request to give
a tour of so this is my home screen as
you can see here i am not using the
stock icons down at the bottom i'm using
a nice little colorful google colored
set of icons and you can find those at
the link in the description uh where i
have it on my google plus profile
so those are some uh the phone icon you
can see
and the people icon which i probably
don't want to show and the messaging
icon which i definitely don't want to
show and the browser which i can
definitely show i do use the stock
browser i kind of been switching back
and forth but i like the stock browser
it's fast and it syncs with chrome right
here in the middle is it says 94 i don't
know if you can read that but make sure
you watch this in hd so you can read
everything this is my battery indicator
this little circle here sort of
indicates how much battery is left so it
actually winds down the circle until i
have zero percent battery which totally
never happens
so down here is extended controls this
is my extended controls widget i got
wi-fi bluetooth brightness and airplane
mode here
i have a ton of apps and i obviously
won't go ahead and open every one but
i'll go ahead and give you a tour since
uh this was requested so much i'm not a
big gamer but the games i have are angry
birds
fruit ninja and zombie dash and i guess
words with friends could be considered a
game too basically i have the amazon app
store because i like the free apps of
the day i have desktop visualizer and
that is how i was able to use these
icons down here i love the search widget
the persistent search widget at the top
is great and i almost constantly use it
to search my phone to search the web and
stuff like that so let's uh swipe over
to the right here
and this is kind of my productivity
slash everyday apps screen i use g tasks
to keep tasks organized foursquare
dropbox google maps google navigation
that saved me a couple times already
twica which is what i use for twitter
and uh pretty sweet client i've opened
this in a video before it's pretty nice
newsrob which is like news google reader
and youtube and the youtube app is
awesome on android in case you didn't
know if you have a samsung galaxy nexus
you know this already watching apps in
full screen in the youtube app here is
an awesome experience
all the way over here on the right i
have my weather and that's beautiful
widgets and if you tap it it opens up
this glorious high definition look at
the weather forecast and it does this on
the tablet too
and down here we have our shopping apps
which are google shopper
and we also have amazon price check and
amazon and a barcode scanner and here i
have some of my settings that i most
frequently use so like my data usage
widget and my battery and apps i'll open
data usage just because i think it's
kind of funny uh since i've gotten this
one i've used 6.6 gigs of 4g
and i've used
3.92 gigs of wi-fi so i've used a pretty
decent amount of data not enough to get
throttled though thank gosh so back to
the left we have spotify which i love
the app could use some work but the
service is great calendar gallery and
camera and all the way here on the left
i just have my starred emails i like to
start emails that i want to get back to
later that's basically it for my phone
uh the setup as it is i don't have a lot
of widgets as you can see
uh but some notable apps i do use
evernote dropbox and google docs which i
use for uh within sync as you probably
already know so
yeah that's basically it so those of you
guys who have been looking to see what's
on my phone
now you know skydroid by the way is what
i use when i'm golfing
soundcloud the speed test app i almost
always have 4g on but when i'm home i
have wi-fi on
yeah and that'll do it that's a tour of
my phone so like i said again if you
like the uh the series idea just go
ahead and leave this video a thumbs up
and let me know in the comments below
what else you want to see a tour of i
love that animation right there i'm
gonna do it again just for cakes
thanks for watching and i will talk to
you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you